for those of you that think you're
competitive i i i have a challenge for
you
uh and and this is a challenge in one
area
where this one area doesn't lie i've
been running a sales organization now
for 20 years
and i can tell you this the one area
that scares the hell out of everybody
when it comes down to showing this one
area
and most people don't like to show this
one area there's an element of
insecurity in it
there's an element of discomfort in it
but those who show this
gain a lot of confidence if they're able
to show it
to everybody let me explain to you what
it is so this last week
we have a very competitive company uh uh
sales company and our guys were going at
it in our private
uh communication platform that we have
and one group saw what we're gonna do
this another one so i'm gonna do this so
we're gonna be number one we're gonna be
this
and then all of a sudden one of our
leaders who's the top earner in the
company matt zappala
just posted a screenshot of his calendar
and then he posted it again and again
and you know what he had
every 30 minutes he had an appointment
back to back to back to back to back to
back to back to back to back
you know who posted their calendars
afterwards nobody
you know why because nobody probably ran
as many appointments that
he was running so what's the moral of
the story
look guys i was running a mentoring call
this week
and one guy asked me a question he says
you know what pat
i struggled with one thing i said what
is it i have a hard time staying
motivated how do you deal with being
motivated
i said look i just want you to know uh
eventually it gets to a point if you're
want if you want to be a leader
amongst leaders you you can't be
motivated anymore
you have to be self-motivated you don't
need others to motivate you
you don't need somebody else to say you
better do this or you better do that you
got to do this
eventually it's got to get to a point
where you got to be motivated
for many years when i was holding my
guys accountable
in my sales offices and my guys were
coming they would say you have no idea
how bad i want to win pat
you have no idea how bad i want to win i
said really
yeah and they would get emotional you
don't even know pat i would say let me
see your calendar
what does my calendar have to do with
anything i said everything
let me see your calendar and they would
give me their open it up
i said you don't want to win that bad
you're just acting are you trying to
convince me that you want to win that
bad
because it's not going to work it's not
going to do anything i said if you want
to show me you want to win that bad
pack your calendar you pack your
calendar that's how you show the world
that you want to win because everything
is based off of activity
last week i did a video talking about
the fact that
the way you measure hunger is through
urgency right meaning you show me
somebody that's hungry i'll show you
somebody that's very urgent period
uh the the hungriest people in the world
are the most urgent about learning
getting better all this other stuff
but in your weekly habits you really
want to show the world you want to win
bad
show it with your calendar very few
people
want to show their calendar very few
want to show their calendar because if
they did
you would realize who really wants to
win bad and who doesn't
because it's not easy for you to
continuously have a packed schedule
day after day after day after day after
day without you winning
let me say it one more time it's
mathematically impossible
for you not to win at the highest level
if your calendar is packed from
day till night every single
day the entire year minus a
sunday that you get to yourself six days
a week this is if you want to win at the
highest level
your calendar has got to be packed and
if your calendars packed
some tells me 2021's gonna be a big year
for you
so having said that i did a video two
years ago titled
seven habits to help you dominate in
2019 those same
seven habits apply to 2021 if you
haven't seen it
click over to watch that video and
having said that have a great week
everybody bye